fanatic cloud9 faze clan optic gaming
and even your most recent major winner
gamma-d sports all made roster moves
this player break and with so many
blockbuster roster moves this past month
we've decided to put together the top 10
roster moves in csgo history kicking off
our list is skadoodle and freakazoid -
cloud 9 replacing some fish and Shazam
the inclusion of a superstar operand
fearless entry Fragger revitalized e9
csgo program in the summer of 2015 with
skadoodle and freakazoid the team broke
into the upper tier of csgo competitive
ranking and began competing for
championships upsetting the likes of
team envyus and fnatic on their way to
three straight land grand final
appearances I think it's just the
underlying issue of mine seeming very a
couple on the CT side yeah and they have
to go for a place somewhere right look
at this skadoodle doing his best simple
impression with the dropping kill and
actually stops to smoke lures what out
he gets another that's four kills first
skadoodle he's tapped the bomb his head
he got a push 40 is plenty of time -
this is a shot now he's gonna get on the
bomb I think he's just gonna stick up
anything he's got a Glock he's got it
coming in at number nine is Dennis's
move to fnatic replacing pronax at the
end of 2015
Dennis's inclusion turned fnatic into
the single most dominant team on the
planet
going on an absolute tear once he joined
the lineup the team won six straight
land titles before an injury to
olofmeister eventually derailed the team
streak of victories
on cue on point all three kills again
I'm done don't even buy guns just this
guy could use a USB for the entire game
and I would be convinced
because g2 is certainly has to be
convinced team I would even say about
how I'm not that's just disgusting
gambit eSports landing hobbit from
Tengri and signing Zeus in late 2016
comes in at 8 on our list replacing
hooch on the lineup Hobbit made an
immediate impact on the roster with
incredible fragging power while Zeus
provided the knowledge and experience to
help the roster perform at its best the
team wrapped up notable title wins at
Dreamhack winter 2016 and Dreamhack
Austin 2017 but they finally peaked at
Cracow where they won a csgo major
at number 7 is Kerrigan - Team Dignitas
taking over the reins from fetish as a
Danish lineup in game leader Kerrigan
took this team of super talented
underperformers and made them into
champions although he ultimately failed
to win a major with the team Carrigan's
influence on the team's well-balanced
style of play is one of the many reasons
why the Danes have stayed so consistent
over the years it's gonna be a real
rough time here for the Danes but look
at this situation Kerrigan two kills for
him still alive as well peaking buying
as much time as he can hoping that a
teammate will be able to support him for
his team speaking of Kerrigan Australis
is decision to replace him with leave
comes in at number 6 on the list
if Kerrigan took the Dean's and made
them into winners glaive elevated them
to major champions with glaive holding
the ring Australia's have remained a
constant within the top two of the world
rankings for almost a year now and it
doesn't look like they'll change anytime
soon
[Applause]
number five on the list is simples
incredible run with North America's Team
Liquid replacing fugly on the lineup
simple took an entire region and made
some relevant on an international level
in back-to-back majors simple took Team
Liquid to a top four or better placing
and they got there by beating quality
teams like fnatic Navi and faze clan to
name a few simple I don't know man if he
comes in with that
that team envyus and titans two-player
swap in 2015 comes in at number four on
our list replacing shocks and Smith's on
seem envious Kenny s and apex would
start a new era of French dominance
placing second in their first major
together the lineup also captured a
major title later that year aside from
their incredible results in tournaments
the team's trademark risky force by play
style which shaped the meta during the
latter half of 2015
stuck in the sight finding more that's
brilliant yes again the noscope on the
3rd this guy's absolutely insane coming
in at number 3 on our list is snacks and
B alley to Universal soldiers as one of
the few constants in csgo virtus Pro is
legendary roster first picked up the -
way back in 2013 though the team has had
their ups and downs the lineup continues
to perform when it matters most placing
within the top eight or better at every
single major so far way to be as well on
Guardian and flaming
[Applause]
number two on our list is FNX taco and
zoos to luminosity gaming although the
original lineup that included steel and
bolts performed admirably on several
occasions the team failed to be anything
more than a dark horse and most events
that all changed with the inclusion of
FNX and taco starting their careers on
LG in one of the most embarrassing ways
possible the lineup shook off a 0 16
thrashing at the hands of fnatic before
rallying all the way to a grand final
appearance in the very same tournament
this feisty in spirited attitude would
become the Brazilian trademark and
thanks to their unshakeable mentality
they captured two major titles the poem
this is such a big risk right now and
fnatic they're just not buying it now
they must have heard him they're gonna
make the rotation but the problem is now
when he plants he can't make it out and
he's stuck in here just getting the bomb
down he's gonna have to take the fight
there after one shot everything
taking our top spot is crimson Olaf to
fnatic replacing Schneider and devilwalk
on the lineup in 2014 the crims Olaf
fuel of fanatics pass will undoubtedly
go down as one of the most dynamic
pairings in the history of the game
olofmeister star power coupled with
crimson consistency set fnatic up for
unparalleled success through the
entirety of 2015 an early half of 2016 I
don't see a way he can bring this to two
individual he won't know as Charles is
playing was so well actually at the
timing just as he goes to plant the bomb
he's gonna go for the noscope because
you can't commit too much there he goes
it's the first one now he has to plant
this bomb he actually pulls the fake
meister those were our picks for the top
10 roster moves in csgo history which
one was the most memorable to you we
want to hear in the comments section
below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button